-A lot a lot of people
don't know about this,
but years ago, you and I starred
in a German soap opera together.
-Well, we were just
starting out, yeah.
-Yeah, Bryan, yeah, of course.
Do you remember the name?
-Oh, God, of course I remember.
I mean, it was, um --
"Das Beats of ze Heart."
[ Laughter ]
-That's right.
For those who haven't seen it,
"Das Beats of ze Heart"
was a soap opera
about all the drama
between German DJs at the time.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-And it only lasted
a short while.
-Some would say too short,
really.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Some.
It's very hard to find a clip
all over the --
We scoured the Internet.
-[ Exhales forcefully ]
-But we do have a clip
from the first episode.
-Do you really?
-Is this unbelievable?
-Oh, my God, I'd love to see it.
-When's the last time
[ Laughter ]
you've seen it?
-Since we did it,
all that, you know, 40 --
50-some odd years ago.
-Yeah. Here we go.
Here's me and Bryan Cranston
in "Das Beats of ze Heart."
Look at it.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ House music pulses ]
-♪ Das ♪
♪ Beats ♪
"Das Beats of ze Heart."
♪♪
-Oh, ja, dis beat is absolutely
out of control, yeah.
♪ Unt unt unt unt ♪
-Oh, ja.
-♪ Unt unt ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Jorgen, this beat goes
way too crazy hard.
-Horst, I was put on zis Earth
for one reason --
to drop insane beats that go --
♪ Unt unt unt unt ♪
-No, the people,
they cannot handle that!
They should be vibing
to a beat that goes --
♪ Woop woop woop ♪
♪ Weeeeep ♪
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Woop woop woop ♪
♪ Weeeeep ♪
is so last year!
This collab right here
is donezo!
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
♪♪
I've been meaning
to tell you something.
I'm starting my next collab
with a hot new DJ named
Heinrich von Beats.
-Ha! Ha!
Don't make me laugh!
[ Laughter ]
-Why?
-Because Heinrich von Beats
is me.
♪♪
Look.
[ House music pulses ]
-What?!
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Wow! That's --
[ Cheering and applause ]
That is so strange.
-Yeah.
-What happened here?
-I love it?
I love it. I was --
I was getting ready to --
-You're going to dance.
-I thought the clip was going
to be longer.
-Yes. That's nice.
-So, I was going to take
my jacket off.
But sometimes, yeah,
I just try to do that
[ Laughter ]
when I cozy up.
-It's just a comfort blanket.
-Are we going to play a clip?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-It was such a great show,
though.
-Really.
-So many twists.
There are so many beats.
-Yo, in fact,
that was the motto
of the show, was,
"For every twist,
there's a beat," remember?
[ Laughter ]
-Your hair looks great.
-Does it?
-I think the air conditioning
is a little high.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah, a little high.
-Blowing your hair around.
But things got even crazier --
I don't know
if you remember this --
in Episode 2.
-Oh, man, do I ever remember
Episode 2.
But that's so weird because
that's also known
as the Lost Episode.
-That actually is
the Lost Episode.
But really, actually,
James Cameron found it
[ Laughter ]
when
he was doing research on a new
"Titanic," uh, bonus feature.
-He found it under the ocean?
-Under the ocean.
It was buried. It sunk
to the bottom of the ocean.
-Wow! That's deep.
-And we found it.
Here's a clip of Episode 2
of "Das Beats of ze Heart."
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Das ♪
♪ Beats ♪
♪ Das ♪
"Das Beats of ze Heart."
♪♪
-Oh, ja!
[ Cheering and applause ]
This beat is straight nastiness.
♪ Unt unt unt unt ♪
♪ Unt unt unt ♪
-Horst, it's time to commence
another collab.
What fat tracks should we blast?
-Ah.
Well, let's go...
[ Cheering and applause ]
I love the part that goes --
♪ Womp womp womp ♪
♪ Eeraaaaah ♪
[ Laughter ]
-No, no. Let's do --
[ Laughs ] Let's do --
[ Laughter ]
Let's do...
It actually is insane.
It goes like --
♪ Unt unt unt unt ♪
♪ Wee wee wee ♪
-Oh, nein!
[ Cheering ]
Nein!
Nein, that track is not
on fire at all.
-Well, you are fired.
From our collab.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
-Well, good!
Because I'm starting
a new collab
with mein long lost son.
-Well, guess what.
I am your long lost son.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ House music pulses ]
♪♪
[ Whistling ]
-Wow.
-That's unbelievable.
-It's incredible.
Incredible stuff and incredible
that we got canceled
after three episodes.
-I know. After seeing that clip,
can you imagine
us being canceled?
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
I thought the acting was good,
almost too real.
-It was fantastic. I mean --
And both --
And you know what happened --
they banned us in Germany.
We're not allowed
to ever return to that country.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, they said --
they said that they'd lift
the ban,
if we return the third episode
to them,
so that they can destroy it.
-I think that's a good idea.
-And, before we're going
to do that,
we're going to show the clip
of the third and final episode
-Oh, my God.
-of "Das Beats of ze Heart."
[ Cheering and applause ]
Look at this.
-♪ Das ♪
♪ Beats ♪
♪ Das ♪
"Das Beats of ze Heart."
♪♪
-Oh, ja!
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Whistling ]
The whole club is vibing
to my freaky-ass thumps
and thrusts.
♪ Unt unt unt unt ♪
-♪ Unt unt unt ♪
-Jorgen, I've come
to do collaboring
with my long lost son again.
[ Laughter ]
-Ja, we will be the most fire
father-son DJ duo
since the Boom Boom Boys.
-Well, I can't believe
this is our life!
-What do you mean?
This is not our lives.
Because I am in a coma.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
And this is my coma fantasy.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, guess what.
You're not in coma.
We're actually
in ze Metavershe.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ House music pulses ]
♪♪
[ Whistling ]
-Gosh.
That was --
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Oof!
-That was ahead of its time.
-Oh, yes!
-I think.
Yes. My thanks
to Bryan Cranston, everybody.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Check out
"Your Honor" on Showtime.